PRESENTER: We covered monitoring
GKE infrastructure and services
in the previous episode.
But GKE is not the only
place you can run containers
in Google Cloud.
Today, we'll look at three
options for running containers,
and how to instrument each
one for observability,
with Cloud Operations.
Welcome to Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
Let's start by
reviewing your options
for running containers
in Google Cloud
and how you might
choose between them.
Your first option is, of course,
GKE, or Google Kubernetes
Engine.
It's a great way to
deploy, scale, and manage
Kubernetes clusters in the Cloud
and use them to orchestrate
your container workloads.
GKE is the industry's first
fully managed Kubernetes
service, and it implements
the full Kubernetes API,
four-way autoscaling,
release channels,
and multicluster support.
Your second option is Cloud
Run, either as a fully managed
serverless offering
or on GKE clusters.
Cloud Run abstracts away
infrastructure management
by automatically scaling
up and down from zero,
and almost instantaneously by
responding to incoming traffic.
And Cloud Run only charges
you for the exact resources
you use.
Your third option is Anthos.
It's a managed
application platform
that extends Google Cloud
Services and engineering
practices to your environment
so you can modernize apps
faster and establish operational
consistency across them.
With so many options,
how do you choose?
GKE is a fantastic option if
you prefer to manage and operate
Kubernetes clusters directly,
or need that level of control
over your infrastructure.
GKE is also great because of
its Google Cloud marketplace
integration, which
lets you access
enterprise-ready
containerized solutions
with pre-built deployment
templates, portability,
simplified licensing,
and consolidated billing.
Cloud Run is a great choice as
a fully serverless platform.
It makes app development and
deployment simple and fast,
and it's fully integrated with
Cloud Code, Cloud Build, Cloud
monitoring, and Cloud Logging
for a complete end-to-end
developer experience.
Finally, Anthos is the right
choice for many enterprises
where hybrid or
multi-cloud is a reality.
It lets you extend the
best of Google Cloud
to your environments, no
matter where they are, so you
can modernize apps and establish
operational consistency
across infrastructure.
Now that you understand
your options,
let's have a look at how
to instrument your services
running on them
to send telemetry
to Cloud Operations for
a consistent approach
to observability.
Let's start with GKE.
We've covered much of
this in previous episodes,
but let's have a look
at how to get visibility
into both the infrastructure
and your services.
Let's start by
inspecting our cluster.
Here, we can confirm that we
have both system and workload
logging enabled, and monitoring
enabled for the cluster.
This means that we'll get logs
from our containers and cluster
infrastructure, and
infrastructure metrics
ingested automatically.
Let's head over to
monitoring and have a look.
We'll start at
the GKE dashboard.
Here, we can see information
about our clusters,
their nodes, and the
workloads and services
running on them, even down to
the pod and container level.
We can select a
specific workload
to get information about it.
Here, we can see if it's
generating any alerts, metrics
that show its
health and behavior,
and the logs it's generating.
In this case, the
workload is a deployment.
If we want to know what pods
or containers are running
in this deployment, we can
filter the entire dashboard
by that resource.
We can then see the actual
container running our workload,
and get its metrics and
even container logs.
Note that workloads
on GKE do not
have automatic tracing enabled.
Have a look at our
previous episode
on distributed tracing
with OpenTelemetry
if this is something you need.
GKE is well integrated
with Cloud Operations,
and makes it easy to
monitor and observe
both your infrastructure
and services.
Now, let's have a look at
managing services on Cloud Run.
From the project dashboard,
let's go to the product menu
and select Cloud Run.
Cloud Run home page
shows all services
running in the project.
When we select our
service, the metrics tab
will show some of the key
performance indicators
like request count, broken
MR response code class,
and latency, with 50th, 95th,
and 99th percentile latencies
automatically calculated.
Metrics that we would want
to use as Service Level
Indicators, or SLIs, are created
for us right out of the box.
We can switch to the logs tab
to see the logs for our service,
and even view them in
the log's Explorer.
Here, we can analyze
and query logs
from our Cloud Run service
using queries, the field
Explorer, or the histogram.
You can review our
previous episode
on Cloud Logging for
more details if you like.
Back on the metrics screen,
we can also open Cloud Trace
and go directly to the list
of traces for our service.
We can select a trace and
see detailed information
for that request,
including total latency
and any dependencies
our service might have.
This is how container
applications running
in Cloud Run are
automatically instrumented
to send metrics, logs, and
traces to Cloud Operations.
Finally, let's have a look
at how Anthos clusters are
integrated with Cloud
Operations to provide visibility
into the infrastructure, no
matter where it's running,
and your services.
From the project dashboard,
let's go to GKE clusters.
Here, we have two clusters
running on GKE in the Cloud
and another cluster
managed by Anthos.
Let's have a look
at how we can start
to visualize the health of
the cluster and the workloads
running on it.
Our first dashboard shows us
the status of the control plane,
including the availability
of the API server, scheduler,
and controller manager.
We can also see the status
of the infrastructure,
and understand how our
nodes are using CPU, memory,
and disk resources.
Finally, we can look at the
status of the actual workloads
running in our Anthos cluster,
by understanding metrics
like container CPU,
memory usage, restarts,
and network traffic.
To understand more about what's
happening with our container
workloads, we can go to logging
and look at logs Explorer.
Here, we can look at
Kubernetes container logs
and filter them through
just the logs being
emitted by services running
in the Anthos-managed cluster.
We can scroll down and select
a specific pod or container
we're actually interested in.
For example, if we want to
get the logs being generated
by our front end, we can select
that as the pod name to filter
the logs to just those.
This is how Cloud
Operations can help
you visualize metrics
and analyze logs being
emitted by your
container workloads
running on an Anthos cluster.
Thanks for joining me today.
We covered your options
for running containers
in Google Cloud, and how to
observe both the infrastructure
and your services for each one.
I hope this helps you run more
reliable container services,
and keep your users happy.
Thanks so much for watching.
Don't forget to
Like and Subscribe
so you never miss out on more
Engineering for Reliability
with Google Cloud.
See you soon.